for both of you uh you're both uh actors
directors writers dancers dancers I'm so
sorry um which project that were you
involved with that changed the most in
the editing room in ways you didn't
expect you mean maybe as an actor that
you see the film when it's different it
could be anything it could be as a
director could be as a writer as an
actor well I think films I think maybe
you you you could speak to this too as a
director the film doesn't change that
much in the editing room away from your
vision because you're kind of shooting
it to figure that out but acting there's
times when you you finish a film and you
go and then all it could either be a
disaster or it could be a much better
film than you thought you were making I
think uh I think Warrior was one that
had had the finish product was so much
different to the original script that's
cuz we were like you know we would
rehearse the scene and change stuff that
you know to expand on a scene but you
know I remember the your question brings
out the first time ever watched the
movie back and was like that
moment was from a scene that I shot on
for a different scene and felt like
betrayed in some way even though I think
it's one of the greatest tricks for a
director to do is go whatever makes the
scene the best if you get a reaction
shot from someone that belonged
somewhere else in the movie just do it
yeah but I remember thinking wow how
would you do that you stolen what I've
done this my heart acting over here for
something anyway Fincher told me that
one of the keys to the way he crafts a
performance is he'll use Take 2 34 39
and 46 and craft it all together
sometimes for someone's performance
sounds like Bingo Right Bingo you know
and I'm like well whatever works he
clearly knows what he's doing absolutely
whatever happens in the edit room I
think is about making the be packing the
best lunch you know yeah uh last
question before the get into the movie
uh what's the most nervous you have been
the night before the first day of
filming on something Kinky
Boots really yeah it was one of my first
big jobs I was doing a a Northampton
accent in front of a factory full of
Northampton that's rough and day one was
my big speech of the movie and I'm
certain if you track down the trailer
that I was staying in that day there's
like finger down marks in it and some
crap on the
floor for me it would be oh brother cuz
I'd never worked with the Cohen Brothers
before and I was nervous uh and I was
playing a big idiot and it was the very
first day of shooting and it's a scene
where John Goodman slugs me the head
with a branch and knocks all this corn
out of my mouth and I was playing him
like an idiot because he's an idiot and
I I did the first take and then Joel
came over goes yeah you know the thing
is you're the smartest person in every
room you walk into that's the only
Direction he gave me but it was perfect
Direction because of course of course
he's right dumb people don't think
they're dumb you know and and it sort of
changed everything but I was very
nervous starting that film question for
you about this movie uh after Perfect
Storm and now this how much more respect
do you have for Spielberg and jaws and
what he pulled off in the 70s I mean can
you imagine that F they the shark sinks
I mean the hell they went through that
must have been you know forgetting that
you're shooting with you know this
disaster you it's a disaster film
everything was going wrong but you're
also getting just murdered by the studio
too you know so it's the pressure of
that and he was you he done tiny you
know mostly done television at that
point and a smaller film so the the the
the pressure that he must have been
under is just insane just insane it's a
masterpiece of a film and it's on the
water in the 70s it's crazy I was
certain this this was going to have an
element of disaster about it cuz
shooting from I was directing it yeah
that and shooting from a boat to another
the boat and just you
know we never we never went over time
crazy that we never went over time and
we so much on the water it's almost like
he's directed before we were prepared
because believe me well you know listen
the other part was this is MGM before
they were bought by uh Amazon and I was
on the hook for any overages like I had
to pay for anything that we went over on
so that's why we're on time yeah that's
why we're on time I have a
responsibility man I'm fascinated by the
editing process I've asked you this
before because it's ultimately where it
comes together
so how did this film uh get shaped in
the editing room like what what did what
did you learn from friends and family
and you're like oh these are really good
notes well we I I didn't screen any
friends and family um uh before we
finished the film IES have any friends I
have no friends and I and my family
won't talk to me so it just really
doesn't work my children had some notes
but that was mostly poo don't poo uh you
know what I had this amazing editor
named Tanya swirling who i' worked with
a few times she did tender bar she did
uh catch 2 to with us and the challenge
for us was our the last race in
particular was we cut it with about 150
Cuts in the race and we sat there and
watched it and it wasn't exciting and as
much as we really worked hard and the
and using the camera as a a tool to make
it exciting we realized that we needed
to triple it and by the end I think we
were at 500 Cuts in that last race just
to create that kind of energy G um so
she's an extraordinary editor and I hope
people pay attention to how good she is
last question for both of you individual
um I'm always excited when you and David
work together so I'm curious what you
can tease about Wizards and and I've
mentioned this in previous times I've
spoken to you I'm a big fan of when
you're acting and I'm incredibly excited
uh for John Watts's movie that you're
doing with Brad Pit yeah because it's
you and Brad Pit and it's John Watts so
can you both can you talk about that
project and why you're excited for
people to see it I I'll tell you one
thing about Wizards I'm I'm going to get
off the plane in Sydney and go to a a
casted crew uh screening of it it
potentially is going to match uh uh the
the the vomit scene in uh Ruben oland's
oh really yeah yeah yeah triangle of
sadness there's a scene in it that
clearly we will talk about when we see
audiences are going to be throwing up
yeah good nice and and and it's sort of
well it's our fault you know obviously
cuz we sat down and we wrote the story
together but it's a it's a b crazy
awesome film and it's going to be so
much fun I'll tell you I'm a Hu never
knew much about him before France rasi
yeah is unbelievably cool Pete Davidson
yes I knew about but France wowski is
like one of my favorite new actors oh
that's fantastic exci anyway over to you
yeah um uh I I really enjoyed working on
Wizards um oh wait uh John wat is John
wats is a genius and he loves what he
does I mean he's one of those guys that
just you know he knows every film
reference he knows everything he's so
much fun to work with I had to you know
carrye Brad of course CU that's a pain
you know he's always always like George
how would you do this I'm like f Jesus
just come up with something on your own
every once in a while make an effort um
but it's fun it's dark man and it's a
it's a it's a real proper fun out there
film you we've seen it and we're really
very excited about it cannot wait for
both of these congrats on this movie I
hope it's a huge hit for you thank you
so much thank you
brother